but you were a cast member who wasn't
being asked to leave you you're going on
your own fruition which that is a crazy
move CRA I agree it's a crazy move but
it felt right I was doing this other
show Portlandia I love Portlandia oh
thank you you see what uh and do you see
what we put a bird on it yes for those
people I love it thank you for doing
that I love that is that fun to do
Portlandia that was a blast I loved it
to write that it's so it's so
wonderfully weird and awkward and just
wonderful I'm glad I'm glad you think so
you I think that's your comfort zone is
awkward yeah and like whatever that
weird zone is I love that and I love
when you're on Seth you know you're as a
uh well not only the drummer and the
band leader and and and whatnot but I
love when he talks to you oh it's it's
fun for me is any of that planned no
purposefully like he'll ask me a
question a random question and we I
never know what it is can I ask you a
random question
sure it's hard to even come up with a
you got you got to go in into it with
like Authority and like you know like
we've you know you're not good at this
Dad you're you're okay at it no well I
haven't done it yet I haven't even done
it I love that fact I love the fact that
you are judging how I am at it and I was
able I said let's do it and then nothing
came to me right and I didn't do it yeah
yet that doesn't stop you from uh
critiquing like the
nothingness yeah that was but which is
kind of I
mean would you could say this is what
you do in AGT what is your take on
Scandal I am so for it in a way that I
would say that I'm at the Forefront
of supporting it um I'm a spokesperson
for it really so you believe uh [__]
your uh girlfriend's best
friend at her most uh uh sensitive time
in life yes not not me myself personally
I'm saying as a
movement the people who do it I support
them I support everyone's decision
right not for me but for others I've got
to be a supporter from
afar okay so if somebody loses their dog
or their grandmother or whatever and
they're really um hurting and pining you
think I mean you're supporting the fact
that their significant other brings a
young girl into the house and [__] her
yes wow for them that's a side that I I
didn't
expect
he